we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
we're back
what's up guys
happy to be here hell yeah i don't know
we're drinking again i kind of like the
surprise element yes i mean you did
bring booze so you know where you're you
know what what ballpark were in you told
me to bring the airplane bottles and
then i was looking at the handle uh-huh
but then like the handle is not a good
look for the bar the handle doesn't look
like a like a cool it looks like you
have a problem yeah handle's bad the
only thing worse than a handle is a
plastic handle you know the jug when you
put that [ __ ] drum of hooch on the
table nothing worse well you know why
because i think it's just because
economical is not sexy that's true bulk
is not sexy it's not why is that what's
wrong i guess you got a big container of
uh you know that yellow popcorn what is
that [ __ ] like the the sweet popcorn
kettle corn it's a bad look but if
you've got a nice little one you know at
the movies it's cute it's unsexy to plan
women want you to plan but if you plan
too much it's unsexy i think because
like
what's what's like like uh women don't
like it but they also kind of like it i
think if a guy's like let's play it by
ear that's true that's true they like a
guy with a plan but it's
spontaneous is sexy spontaneous is sexy
yeah cause it feels like you're
you're over thinking a little bit right
right and you're quick on your feet if
you're spontaneous and what about that
grasshopper in the ant remember that old
fable from the sea yeah how does that go
again the grasshopper is playing is
putting acorns in the hut all day in his
little cave and the ants going ah blow
me your queef we're gonna we're gonna
live it up this winter yeah yeah it was
aesop yeah he was a homophobe or
whatever but he was like
by the way everybody you look like roald
dahl was a rabid anti-semite but he
could visualize a giant peach in a
chocolate factory but not the jews were
equal for some reason yeah exactly
so uh
also who's going to who's going to
finance the factory but we'll get to
that later so asap who's who is running
fables other than aesop that guy had a
[ __ ] he got all of them this mother
goose but i don't know what happened to
her she's kooky but either way
the grasshopper stored all the nuts and
the fruits and the veggies or whatever
and the ant the winner came and i was
like can i stay with you i forgot to
save and he was like i told you
so that's that the grasshopper opened at
trader joe's
[Laughter]
yeah
uh remember trader ming that was a whole
thing what did we lose matt here oh god
we lost bat matt that's are we still
running here he was slowing us down he's
dead weight
now i'm just kidding hey you're back all
right did we get all that okay good but
like we were in there in nasa going
there we lost houston there's no memory
card stressing me out that's what i said
speaking of remember the movie apollo
13. that's what i was referencing that's
that was like great movie it was great
and greg r.i.p bill paxton great actor
oh yeah yeah weird that he's dead i know
because he was kind of just low-key good
in everything i know i hate that i just
had low-key he was high-key good yes
what is low-key [ __ ] low-key everyone
knows everything's low okay he's a
that's another one sleeper he's sleeper
a good actor like no he's a good actor
we're aware he's a good actor
he made he made a career at acting he
was rich from acting he was the
president in independence day for
christ's sake that's back when movies
that was like right before no it's bill
pullman you're thinking oh
they're the same person well pullman was
the president in so many movies he's
such a white guy with a full head of
hair president look
him in a suit looks like the real deal
he was like right before they started
only casting black men as president yes
right before right before like 24 and
deep impact yeah you know exactly yeah
but that had a black lead that was like
will smith you know black lead black
family black star
and uh you got you got a little judd
hersh in there for you for your people
they threw a little jewelry
yeah and he was in taxi of course he was
about to see the right i gotta watch
taxi oh
taxi's great okay i'll watch it i mean
that is a classic comedy second devito
tony danza mary lou henner christopher
lloyd is amazing i love christopher
lloyd yeah i gotta everyone tells me
it's great and it's like all those
simpsons writers exactly yeah you gotta
watch it that's big stuff yeah i hope
you're getting a shot of this uh matthew
cause this is what what are we doing
here i want to know the beer i picked up
gin i'm in the store yeah it's it is
weird because i went during the day it
is weird when you see the uh the
regulars in the liquor store during the
day i saw a guy having a casual
conversation you're like oh i do not
want to be that guy no that's a bad you
want to walk in and be like oh we've
never met you you're like damn right you
haven't
i'm not a it's like norm from cheers
hey sam
you want the usual oh my god garnish
this looks like a smoothie a hawaiian
thing i can't tell if it's frothy is
that a raspberry
what the [ __ ] so today we're having the
uh clover club it's an old school
pre-prohibition drink uh
with gin raspberry syrup
lemon and um
egg white
egg white yeah egg white egg white mark
wanted an egg white drink and we already
did the whiskey sour so i went a little
fancy i'm slipping off the chair i'm so
wet i had two drinks i could sell manila
i'll tell you
i thought i got these aborted
not in texas
oh my god beer jew has done it again i
was just in texas oh
yeah it's in texas one night for a week
hold on
interesting
whoa
that's really good that's amazing these
are the dangerous ones where you can't
like you get a little bit of that sharp
alcohol
but it's pretty smooth man that was
actually really strong that has uh three
ounces of ginger per drink
driving the hog today that's his way of
saying he's uh he's jacking off in
public
what uh
you drove here on the scooter
you didn't see it out there no i hope
nobody yanked it already
another way of talking about his dick
but
i hope that guy
but no i hope no one stole it but i
locked it up you locked it up does that
stress you out though a little i've had
so many things stolen from me as a child
that it's like a triggering thing i'm
always looking out the window in my
apartment i can see it on the sidewalk
and you've been robbed i've been robbed
so many times like in new york even
though yes yes exactly and the tow truck
guys are robbers they'll swoop in like a
bat out of the hell or whatever it is
that the phrase
those guys are so stealthy
um
stealthy low-key a pretty good word
no what sleeper i would dude i was just
in texas and uh
austin
good time we had a good time i i think
it's the last festival i ever do oh
really
i'm kind of done with festivals same
same they're fun you just black out
every night eat like [ __ ] and you get a
10-minute set at least you did some
hours yeah i only did hours that's good
yeah um you get the meal you get to hang
out with soda and all these guys and
you're at a diner and barbecue
yeah i had a good time caught dana gould
and bobcat made a movie
called joyride it's really good it's
coming out next month look out for it
interesting really funny it's about how
they used to hate each other in the 90s
and now they're best friends whoa
i'll watch the hell out of that
really good i can't and it's a little
dock yeah we saw it uh we saw it in the
theater they did a q a it was fun man
i'm in
and uh
bobcats sweetest guy gould funniest guy
i'm sold and bobcat low-key great
director
he really is he's also he is really
funny man yeah yeah i i worked on a show
with dana ghoul for seven months and it
was the first time we met that's crazy
we did every day on zoom because it was
new york la during the pandemic that's
so great because you have the zoom
barrier and then you have to get to know
each other
on zoom and work together i mean when
you but you end up just becoming like
pals he's the best he's he's awesome and
uh yeah see him in real life is it like
oh my god is it is it love yeah it's a
huge crazy that's nice that's nice
blaine capac super funny guy
one of the apparently like the best guy
in a writer's room oh i mean i follow
him on twitter
they're gold every joke every tweet is
gold zinger after zinger puns misdirect
he's got them all i don't know why he's
not bigger maybe he's getting up yes
he's he's a he's a huge a very sought
after writer oh he's a sought after
writer okay but you know yeah he's a
girl really funny stand up too he still
goes on yeah okay um told me this
amazing story i don't know if this is
okay to share but i don't know why it
wouldn't be it seemed like a pretty ah
lay it on me later on yeah all right it
was just about martin it seems like a
story that's out there but he said you
know i was talking about how i love
martin short and he just said one time
at a party he just walked in and made
eye contact with him and just started
doing gags like only for him like walked
over to the bar and started taking the
wine bottle and going ugh
and like he's such a he's like a buster
keaton type where you do physical sure
so he's shaking the wine he's shaking
the glasses he's shaking and it's like
two minutes of just physical comedy for
him he's like that's how he is wow can't
not be hilarious i love it i mean he's a
national treasure that guy well canadian
but
he's so i mean as a kid i worship martin
short yeah his old sc tv is s and also
three amigos three amigos what's the one
where he goes in a little pod and they
go into his body
oh inner space i never saw that one give
it a goog and he's in clifford
but i never saw clifford oh he's great
in clifford he's amazing he's great
i'll toast a short sure yeah man this
drink is good it's good that what uh
where are you
where were you over the weekend
[Music]
i was in uh
providence rhode island smallest state
in the nation that's a good club yeah
great club not a hiccup not a problem
every show sold out no hecklers i
couldn't believe it because that can be
like a towny room you know what i mean
it is it is but yeah they're good people
you get like some die-hard people might
drive from boston
it is weird because it's like it's in
between boston and new york basically
right
it's in between two bigger cities
exactly and it's a small estate but i
gotta say
i don't know about living there but for
a weekend it's like a perfect town like
most places are perfect for that's a
good three nights but it was like clean
and i walked around i went to brown
university and uh it's beautiful and
there's like a farmer's market and all
this [ __ ] and the river's running right
through there's a guy with the gondola
you know the italian guy
and you can rotate island yeah because
it's so italian
damn it's mob run which
yeah these mob run cities i say what you
will about uh
the wise guys but
they uh they clean a town up yeah
apparently vegas ran way more smooth
that's what i heard when when the mob
was in charge yeah i mean look they
could also uh throw you in the ocean or
bury it you know up to your neck in the
desert but
you know they kill a few people who owe
money overall it helps the local economy
exactly here here here
don't speak enough don't kill us by the
time this comes out we're recording this
one uh earlier in the week by the time
this comes out
the many saints of newark will be out
you know i'm fired up that trailer i was
jerking it i mean that is like my cup
that [ __ ] 70s gritty look i love that
[ __ ] love david chase and we got a paul
thomas anderson coming out ooh movies
are popping again maybe we can get rid
of captain america's queefy ass and get
back to some cinema
yes scorsese really uh he went to town
oh the avengers and the nerds they they
revolted i loved it i loved when he was
like going to the and i'm i've no beef
with these superhero movies but like at
a certain point we got enough
i just turned into a cash grab they're
like completely they're like
once we've gotten to hawkeye has a
series
let's maybe hold off i know the hawkeye
what are we doing we're scraping the bro
here comes anal fissure
like how many uh how low are we gonna go
hawkeye what are we doing here although
i do hear the new one that ronnie chang
is in is great oh we love ronnie people
are saying that's great okay i don't
know that one what's it called shang shi
is it go yes oh geez it's supposed to be
great all right i've only i haven't
heard one person say a bad thing about
it all right but that's like that's like
the black panther for asians like they
they need at least one come on yeah
but then it turns into like this
extended universe [ __ ] and then if we're
doing an extended universe sopranos is
the one oh you got that right we're like
star wars nerds but for sopranos yeah
dude exactly 98 audience score but the
difference is there is a mob there is
italian people there are um you know
crimes that happen so at least it's
somewhat based on reality this is a an
asian guy whose hands turn to fire
apparently this is supposed to be the
good one all right all right
i'm just saying look it's
not a good one but like even batman you
got christopher nolan you got uh what's
the other guy with the voice
bale and there's a new one with robert
pattinson is there v batman it's called
nolan
no
[Music]
i feel like like robert pattinson might
have gotten like i know he's rich but
that guy might have gotten [ __ ]
because he's in a nolan movie tenet
which comes out it's like a huge movie
and it comes out during the pandemic
bombed yeah yeah it came it's a bit it's
a movie theater movie that you're doing
a pandemic and now he's in the batman
which it's like
no nolan well no nolan but it's also
it's still a pandemic these are movie
things yeah
yeah
no one's going out that's tough but
maybe they're just not bad like i don't
know if that one like i feel like a lot
of these movies are coming out on on hbo
max yeah that's the move now but i think
if they do put this out in theaters i
bet people will see it this is like the
true test batman a new batman come on i
wonder if he'll be good because now he
with the hair i'm like is this like emo
batman what the hell are they doing no
he was already getting too emotional
do you like the the nolan batman's i do
just because nolan's so good and they're
so well done but i like the 60s i like
adam west i want to all go all the way
but i like them it was a little
tongue-in-cheek you know they're like
watch out there robin that lady's all
tied up or whatever you know and she was
like tied up and it was kind of hot it
was fun and robin was super gay and they
have tights on and now he's bi and now
he's bi
which is great go nuts go nuts but i
just liked it with silly you know bam
pow ban na na
now it's like everybody's got a a
bone to pick and an axe to grind and
they hate their dad and they're they're
in a protest
it sucks can i give you my wreck for
this week early oh that was quick
because we're talking about
i feel like it fits what you're talking
about because it goes against this is
everything is so brooding and dark that
now something bubbly and light almost
feels edgy
oh
well so the fact that everything is like
and then i cheated and stabbed someone
and you know it's like everything else
so my my wreck
is
a heartwarming show
on apple called ted lasso oh
man you're the 18th guy to recommend
that today a reason all right all right
i i'm like you when when four people
wreck a show i'm like maybe i'll watch
it when 12 i'm like eat [ __ ] exactly
because then it feels like homework yeah
exactly i will say after the pilot i was
like i don't know after two or three
episodes i was like this is [ __ ] good
all right well it feels like america is
craving this because i watched the pilot
and i was like all right he's super
dopey
here's what's great about the show
is that every character has depth
as the show goes on you can give an
episode to any character of almost in
like the way that like any other the way
any character in the wire could have an
episode right you know it's and it's as
different from the wires it gets my only
issue with the show is like
it's so heartwarming that that sometimes
the cynic in me is like all right yeah
that's all i can do there's one episode
where one of the soccer players is um
it's about a a football coach who knows
nothing about the football team
basically he's being set up to fail by
the owner who just had a divorce
and her husband loved nothing more than
the team so she's trying to purposely
destroy the team by bringing in an
american football coach
that's good he does it but he's got a
lot of buzz but he doesn't know soccer
and he takes the job
so it's kind of like a major
league-esque plot i got a good premise
but and he's all all shucksy and and
likable and
if it's stupid it's ned flanders
coaching a football team and he's got
the mustache but perfect way to put it
i'll say this man
there's one episode where i'm just like
there's a couple moments where you're
like all right dude yeah like there's a
soccer one of the soccer players on a
dating app and all the teammates are
around him and he's like she answered
and you're like
you guys are knee deep and poon you're
pro athletes shut the [ __ ] up that's
right other than that
it is it is truly
a unique show which is rare now i've
heard so much great he's great and
there's a guy who plays roy kent who's
the best character on the show okay he's
the he's like the tough aging star
all right he's passes prime he's angry
he's got issues he's [ __ ] hilarious
kind of like a ripped torn yeah but he's
still playing soccer oh okay okay i
can't picture
i can't picture riptorn uh as a
footballer good point good point but he
was a
bar brawler back in his day apparently
oh dude rip torn on larry sanders oh the
man you're the best
but all right thank you beard but i will
check out ted lasso on your wreck you're
the 19th guy give it
three episodes i'll give it three and if
you're not satisfied then bail all right
all right i hate when people say that
[ __ ] yeah but with this one it is true
[Laughter]
all right low-key we'll see what happens
i'll try it i'll try it i do it in a new
show and i've burning through everything
and everybody loves i think they just
want an emmy if i'm not mistaken seven
seven yeah jesus it made me get apple i
was like [ __ ] old and then now that i
have apple i'm like [ __ ] i'll try the
morning show what the hell yeah
i mean now that i have it i'm like yeah
what the hell yeah aniston's still uh
holding up yeah it's it's it's not bad i
watch the
first step it's not bad wow they got you
this is how they it's like a game plan
there's some big guy in a suit up in a
board room with a skyscraper going all
right we'll get ted lasso we'll rip sam
morrill in we'll rope him in and then
boom we'll get him on the morning show
and the rest is history well i'll say
this about
this thing one other thing that bugs me
about it there's so much apple product
placement
like i'll watch other shows and it's
like you know when when you're watching
another show and the techs are just
coming in like on the screen yeah this
one it's always on an apple the phone's
always ringing it's the apple ring geez
this is crazy is it ever enough is it
yeah at one point you expect them to be
like updating new and you're like ooh
this update's gonna be pretty good right
here
i will say i feel like this heart
warming thing is good we need it right
now
but i worry it's going to become a trend
everything does everything becomes a
trend it'll swing back and it'll swing
back but it's going to be four years of
this but right now it's like when the
country is this divided right
a heartwarming show is actually it
actually is nice it is very nice we need
it i don't watch anything else like this
so to me it's refreshing good point but
if we get heartwarming in porn i'm
moving to canada
i'm going to afghanistan i'm going to
kabul i'm not going to have better porn
in kabul ah good point good point all
right i'm going to mexico
i'll see a donkey you're gonna go to
kabul to detox
i would joke off with my thoughts yeah
and no alcohol
you know the thing about porn stars is
uh because athletes now there's this
whole like push back against the vaccine
yeah well kyrie irving is unvaccinated
and that would make and so is andrew
wiggins who plays for the uh
warriors so you can't play home games
because california new york are states
you need to be vaccinated so
i'm sure they'll end up getting it
eventually but it made me think about
like porn stars you know there's like a
porn star out there who like because i'm
sure they're doing some porn sets you
got to be vacs to be on the set oh we're
doing everything you're ready right yeah
don't you think there's like someone
who's like
you know not going to disclose their
status where they're just like yeah i'll
take two [ __ ] at a time but
vaccine status that's personal
right completely oh that's i'm sure
that's already happened i'm sure yeah
that's true well i think they have to
get std tests sure so like hey what's
the difference
you know you want that needle you got to
get that needle aha
yeah uh porn stars man
they're they're interesting because
they're like us
you know they're insecure
they're they're they're putting their
life on the line
i've never looked in the mirror
shirtless and been like you know i'm
just like a porn star
wow
not that but i think you could you could
do a decent porno really yeah have you
ever watched a video of yourself doing
it oh once again through the computer
it's different that's true they know how
to make it look good it's true you watch
one the lighting's bad you're just like
staying in one place
it's like when you see those old
vaudeville style like jerry lewis goes
on he's like how you doing folks and
then right when he walks off stage he's
like give me a it's like krusty the
clown you know he hits a lady kicks a
kid in the face and he's like ah where's
my plane you know i feel like they must
be like that because they have to act
sexual all the time and we have to act
funny well then how do you even feel
confident going into acting auditions oh
god no well then where do you get off
thinking that you could do a porno well
i'm saying you could do one you're like
a swarthy guy tall i feel like you could
knock one out but i i'm not saying
become a porn actor yeah i don't think
it's gonna happen all right all right
well we're all waiting for it
maybe one will get leaked how how would
uh jeez now you're scaring me
no you're fine but uh yeah man
it is a weird career i know what you
mean though it's like
in terms of comparing them to us it's
like it's freelance
their parents are probably not thrilled
true
yes and they don't know when the next
gig is coming right
right yeah and
just like me i don't want them to see me
live you know i'm like my mom's like i'm
coming to the show i'm like no no you're
gonna hate it
it's 20 minutes on clits like what are
we doing here but i don't know i think i
think they're sitting with strippers too
i see a stripper and i go i relate
you're working it you're trying to get
some cash you're using what you got to
to get by in life maybe you have no
skills
similar yeah and just like strippers
like when someone tells you to do your
thing off the clock yes go [ __ ] yourself
exactly tell me a joke right yeah all
right dude the only difference is no one
has ever said i'm paying for college
with comedy
that's never going the other way
that's true
comedy i'm yeah i'm just i'm just trying
to uh become a doctor through these open
mics at a taco shop
did you go to college i did where'd you
go oh you went to tulane for a minute
for a year and a half and then i went to
uh nyu what yeah that's a great list
are great you know credits and i went to
columbia for one term because you'd go
anywhere when you were displaced from
katrina so i was just like yeah [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it took a film class yeah
columbia is beautiful i used to temp up
there for like a year it was beautiful
it's beautiful i mean i used to pile up
i used to hand up flyers there for hours
i remember just like
just handing out the the comedy flyers
and like when you handed out flyers in
times square it was yeah it was okay
because there were so many people the
time would just move right but when
you're doing it up by columbia no one
it's like a very desolate area it is
yeah it's a weird new york area it's
like 200 and something right no no
early low hundreds 112. yeah yeah yeah
sorry i think there's an office up in
two something but
yeah i didn't know you you were walking
around with a stack of books at nyu i
had no idea yeah i mean it's not really
it's not like a stack of books really
well you know what i mean you were a
student yeah that's crazy i had no idea
i mean i've told you this before i mean
nyu that's like
hard to get into what if they help the
locals out you know they go hey you live
here i transferred in so i think it's
easier
because i was like i'll go to new
orleans i'm like i can't live in the
south
i know you got the [ __ ] out of there i
was like i would katrina too
katrina like i went i saw i remember
seeing a therapist there and
we have those i didn't know that dude it
was at uh he was a therapist like in the
hospital at the ninth ward wow so he was
like it was it looked like i was seeing
a shrinking shutter island yeah yeah
those are tough to i mean that's already
a rough neighborhood then katrina just
ruined it it just flattened it i
remember he would roast me
i was like this guy i love the guy but
i'm like i don't know if he's my type of
therapist yeah
i'm just picturing like this fat chef or
like an alligator with glasses like oh
look at this i guarantee you're dead
your dad leaving [ __ ] you up boy
well i remember he said to me once when
i was a baby he was like talking about
me being a baby and like like a
three-year-old and he was like you and
mommy against the world and i was like
dude what the [ __ ]
i remember i told a friend there who was
kind of [ __ ] up i was like man you
need therapy because it was like helping
me yeah and and uh he was just a close
friend of mine my buddy elan uh he
edited i got this actually oh wow he's
an editor oh nice he edited the chili
peppers doc i don't know when that's
coming out but yeah he's a great editor
and he uh
i remember telling him to go see the guy
and he's like the guy just [ __ ] on me
for an hour i'm like yeah you got to go
i was like it's like 10 lessons you got
to go a few sessions right right right
wow that's so fun i mean i'm i'm not
surprised growing up there i mean i told
people i was going to do comedy like all
right your theater queef shut up pick up
those boxes you know like that's how it
was it's very the ceiling for ambition
is very low it's a lot of like laissez
faire kick your feet up have a beer and
shut the [ __ ] you're an ambitious guy
though yeah that's why i got out i mean
it's a low it's like a brad williams
ceiling there and i saw him in texas
this weekend oh great guy greatest guy
funny quick quick [ __ ] i mean
not physically yeah but uh short legs
yeah exactly yeah but man he's got a big
head but uh super funny guy super funny
and uh yeah i saw summoned the improv
one night man he's a strong act oh he
kills yeah yeah yeah go see brad
williams yeah we uh yeah so many fun
people at uh moon town man and i'll tell
you i i rallied here's a weird thing
about last week so
we did it was the only episode where we
didn't have any alcohol because even the
episode we did coffee we did the gnome
oh that's a good point so it was the
only episode we don't have alcohol
i had green juice with you and salakus
it was the most upset my stomach has
been after an episode by him how funny
is that the one time we're trying to be
good i had diarrhea all day i was in so
much pain what i had to fly
i had the runs all day i had to fly that
day to austin i'm with my girlfriend
she's coming with me for two days just
to like hang out for a couple of years
for sure and
and
you know since she's hanging out she's
like we're getting good meals so i was
like i'm gonna rally i'm gonna be a team
we went to some damn good places in
texas but like i think we ate tacos four
straight meals yeah and i was like i
don't know if you guys know a lot about
diarrhea but uh
austin tacos are not the best yeah you
you can't get an abortion down there but
you had a miscarriage i swear to god
holy [ __ ] something something came out
of me that was alive at one point i was
like i don't know well don't tell your
uber driver he'll get sued i named it
but
yeah you know i'm trying to think about
something you'd name a piece of [ __ ] oh
this is uh the avengers all right
i called the smallest one hawkeye
what i call my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay
it's tiny this is a cool shirt you got
on oh this is a herschel throw me i got
free new balance sent me a ton of [ __ ] i
don't know why wow those are those are
fun i would never buy these they're too
high and i can't wear a high top it's
not your style not at all
but they're free so i wear them and this
was free and i don't know what these are
but it was raining so i put on a lot of
like slick [ __ ] like non-absorbent
but yeah thanks for the free [ __ ] free
shit's great this shirt was free from uh
henley h-n-l-y they got great [ __ ]
i feel like a henley there was a lot of
those henley shirts are wearing these
they're all free really this one this
one's on yeah they just tag them or
something no they're la-based and i just
i think they sent me they're like can we
send you stuff and they're sure then
they saw i started wearing this so they
sent me more wow
well there you go you see you get a
plug-in they're smart this is good
business good business so keep sending
[ __ ] send us a bidet we'll take a dump
on screen yeah what the hell hell i got
all these good sponsors what the hell
happened to hello tushie hit us up we're
talking about wanting a bidet we'll
[ __ ] plug you we're talking right now
butt plug
yeah you're right i mean i told my girl
i was like we might get a bidet she was
like oh we gotta get a bidet we gotta
get a bidet so
it's already planted in the head now i
gotta get one i gotta give another plug
out and it's someone we plugged before
but like man so i'm in austin i'm in uh
the stateside theater i did a bunch of
shows in there good theater right next
to the paramount which is the beauty
both are beautiful yeah i caught the end
of david tell set
he was right next to me
and it's david tell he's on stage with
like you know louis cats who was killing
it underrated
who was killed they were both on fire
great guys funny guys ian's really funny
and and uh so is louis and obviously and
and dave is a jedi yeah and uh he really
is they're all killing it and
adele had just so many good lines yeah
they got a standing o at the end whoa
it was pretty cool and i'm just in the
back peaking
and
uh
yeah it was i mean if you are near dave
attel on the road and you don't go
you're [ __ ] insane you're crazy he's
one of the best comics ever i don't
think there's a better comic to see in a
club period i completely agree i think
he's genius savant level i think he's
alive and and kicking so go see him now
because who the [ __ ] no we just had the
norm talk i would say the same about
colin quinn energy out there i'm not
putting it out there i'm just saying
good point about colin quinn we did a
thing with salaccus when norm died and
obviously we were so scatterbrained yeah
he was like well who are people you want
to say that to right now we said to tell
we said burr i think yeah colin quinn is
one
as new yorkers people ask us who comics
who like inspire us it's it's a tell and
quinn yeah hell yeah i mean two of the
best and quinn
influenced to tell i mean dave says that
i don't know but uh yeah they're just
both new york guys both great and i feel
like a tell is a special case because
he's doing
comedy at such a high level and comedy's
gotten changed a lot over the years and
stories and
identity stuff and he's just like still
doing that ratatat joke machine gun
style
and so see it while you can folks
because it is it's something special
it's next level it's a great point you
make because so i think about the point
i think about how tony and the sopranos
would always say whatever happened to
the strong silent type the gary coopers
that's what it tells yes of stand up
stand up he's not up there like and then
i was molested
here's a long-winded story with no
punchline about it it tells up they're
like
oh yeah oh yeah and hating himself the
whole time going i suck i could be
better like you're the greatest you're
the best i mean he's the rick flair of
comedy
he's incredible it's almost like in a
western the the older gunslinger who's
just like the quickest shot ever and
everyone's like don't [ __ ] with him yeah
and ian is so great because ian has been
on the road with him for a while now so
he knows how to set him up he knows the
rhythms because
i don't know about you but i've been on
stage with dave
a bunch of times and it's like
i'm a fan he's he's one of my heroes
he's one of the greats and i want to
just give him the floor but he also
wants you to participate but you also
don't want to step on him so it's i'm in
my head the whole time and i was i was
never great me neither okay
i had a few where we had really good
ones together but yeah i mean what's
great about dave is if you're off he'll
save it he's true
you're it's literally like in you know
spider-man when someone falls and he
just like shoots a web and slings down
and catches yeah that's what a tell does
with
except for that time when spider-man
shot at mary jane's neck and broke it
but other than that
deep nerd cud damn
yeah no but he uh i always shoot on the
lower back it's safe
what at the tattoo yes i said yeah one
time i was on me and che went out
drinking one night this was like six
years ago
and we went out drinking one night and
we just ended up at the cellar we're
drinking we're drinking we're like seven
scotches in yada yada so che is famous
so he's like they're like go on you
should go on he's like all right [ __ ] it
but you got to come with me because he
didn't want to do a set i was like i
don't want to go up there i'm not famous
they know you i'll be in the way and
he's weird yeah
it's weird but he's like i just don't
want to just let's just hang out i'm
like all right
so me and shay are on stage and we're
doing great i mean i'm kind of bombing
because they're just like we want to
hear him but i was just zinging and zang
and i was making shay laugh and then
dave atel just walks in so now it's me
che and dave oh wow and it was like this
crazy night because i'm i'm trying to
like sober up and i'm all
googly-eyed and drunk and shay's drunk
and a tell it was just like
not only is he great but he's sober so
he's just
i mean it was like a laser beam and we
were both like ah you you take it and
chase started playing the piano and then
and then dave started roasting me and he
made
he saved it but dave will dave will zing
you on the way to singing yes it's like
it's like it's like a jab before he
knocks it so he's like he'll say like
before he insults he'll be like sam
you're a vampire what do you think about
like it's like boom you're like wait did
i just get insulted
he's quick and he says things that
aren't even jokes but the way they like
i i said a line that bomb and he goes
we'll be right back and that kill and
you're like why is that funny but it is
it's he's such a genius
wow he's really quick i mean yeah he's
great he's he's next level i'm telling
you he's i mean you know you were you
were uh you worshipped him
before comedy yeah the way you looked at
uh norm i always looked at a tail i
always thought like you know oh geez
this guy with the apron you are my god
you're going to be the end of me beard
these are a little
teeth underwear folks wearing it right
now look at that i'm wearing it too look
at that hey there you go we gave
ourselves a melvin that's what they call
in the front melvin i haven't said that
word in 20 years a [ __ ] nerd name
it's a great never name your kid melvin
no bad name bad that's a rough one
if that kid doesn't get the [ __ ] kicked
out of him then he has just become such
he's surpassed expectation oh yeah keeps
your balls off your leg there's two
pouches one for your dong one for your
sack
keep the ammo separate from the gun it's
super supportive they look good they
feel good they're like stretchy and
silky at the same time
the lady likes them she's like you look
great in that look at these these are
camo like weird cameras dude i have
those at home too i would never buy
these but when i put them on i feel cool
as hell your dick was in the gulf war i
love it
yeah i got a sandy hook or no wait sandy
dick [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] this is a plug man i'm
sorry this guy was in the iraq war by
the way this guy's a badass oh yeah he's
a veteran support a veteran this guy's a
a great he's a great dude yeah he's a
veteran he loves comics which is why
he's on this podcast
uh
go to sheath underwear dot com and order
with promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order and sheath underwears 100
back money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls
oh it's so thick
perfect pour right at the meniscus yeah
low key good word
next round next round you're gonna have
to shake up and shoot in my tits because
this is thick
this is good stuff
baby what um man tits are the only tits
that you can get rid of and grow back
yeah isn't that weird women are just
stuck with their tits
i guess they can get fake ones or you
could oh you get surgery you get
reductions true man remember the first
time i heard about a tit reduction you
were like why what are you crazy yeah i
know oh my god we're like i remember i
knew a girl with huge breasts yeah she
was like i know i have back problems i
was like i didn't know that that was i
didn't either no good idea we were so
selfish yeah yeah exactly but i like
looking at them slightly bigger please i
know i know it's funny how there was
always one woman in high school with
huge cans and it was like the talk of
the the entire state you know i remember
when i was i went to public school in
new orleans and it was this woman sophie
i'm not gonna say her last name but she
had gigantic she was a skinny railthin
with like insane jack-o'-lantern tits
and uh i was like my dad's like oh
sophie's over there like everybody knew
her the president knew her the mayor
knew her the garbage men knew her
sophie
[Laughter]
it's amazing that all people
who are adults have to notice giant
minor tits i know it's so unacceptable
but it's like they're there you can't
not look yeah you're not looking but
they're they are there they're there
yeah and it's just it's an anomaly it's
like a guy who's seven foot two you're
like wow that's crazy yeah i remember
one time eating dinner with my friends
parents
and they're french and they're like oh
how about sophie's tits and i'm like oh
yeah the mom was saying that i'm like
yeah yeah yeah i guess that's okay yeah
i guess that's okay
it was still like well now i'm hard
we're dinner it's weird
yeah young mark well you got me hard you
got to finish me off i mean
yeah you're for dinner
right
oh yeah man the french are fun man oh
yeah wine cigarettes chocolate chocolate
just culturally they've got it going on
i saw they had breathless the goddard
film playing at the forum is that right
yeah you ever see that one it's been a
while but is that the true foe or godard
oh guitar sorry yeah um you said that
i'm a i got down so i'm a good dart but
uh
you're mentally good artist it meant
like a daughter that's better yeah all
right beard you will see it thank you
this is unbelievable this is
you raspberried us
uh yeah yeah my friend works there uh
you know eric eric eric's direct eric
edited full capacity now on youtube yeah
keep watching he's the real deal cause i
feel like we're like i love old movies
i'm a film buff and i'm like ah this guy
works at the film forum [ __ ] you yeah
yeah he's the real deal no he loves it
yeah but that [ __ ] goddard and truffaut
that was all
influenced uh wes anderson uh quentin
tarantino all that [ __ ] sure sure
what uh give me a give me a ride oh yeah
i got all i got rex i made a good list i
was actually proud of myself i did my
homework
okay well this is very awkward that i'm
wrecking this why because we brought it
up earlier and trashed it but i'm
wrecking
buying bulk
oh because here's what i've been doing
lately we just said it's not sexy i
don't think i i actually think it's a
good idea it's just not hot it's not hot
yeah no one wants to be married
no no single guy is going to costco
exactly the married guy move great point
so
i've been sitting in my house like
where's we need to charge it we don't
charge my girlfriend's using the charger
i'm our fiancee and i'm like i need the
charger she's like i'm using it so i'm
like [ __ ] this we're making a couple
bucks now i bought like i went on amazon
i bought 10 chargers because you lose
them you throw one in your suitcase you
throw one in the bathroom whatever just
did the same thing really about like
five yeah but i thought about five
they're great because
i just have them in different outlets
around the apartment now so whatever
corn whatever nook i'm in i don't have
to
grab it and move it around exactly and i
did it with toothbrushes i'm like i had
a toothbrush i've cleaned my [ __ ]
with it my sneakers you know
the man great whatever and i got rid of
it and i just like give me 20 why do i
need to go out realize i need a new
toothbrush go to cvs
go to the register i just order 20 on
amazon boom i'll never go to go with cbs
again yeah man amazon unfortunately just
they just make [ __ ] too easy it's easy i
can't beat it i get weird i get weird
[ __ ] off amazon like you know like what
okay
all kinds of [ __ ] man so we're in we go
to this place uh downtown austin that
was like the best taco truck just yeah
when they don't speak english you're
like there's gonna be a good taco
authentic and uh
so we did that then there's a great
coffee shop right next to her so i'm
with the girlfriend she goes in she gets
a uh
she likes matcha with oat milk matcha is
good i'm a coffee gotcha it's like kind
of like concentrated green tea so it's
like stronger green tea and they and
they make it into a latte all right it's
not i'm a coffee guy but i it tastes
good all right matcha man yeah a lot a
lot of a lot of people love it and they
made it with lavender for her
and i was like that's pretty that sounds
nice so i was like i got some lavender
syrup and some dried lavender make some
of that [ __ ] at home let's have some fun
la has moved to austin that's it and
they really have that's that's over well
it's not for me it's for the ladies
i do my warm cups of coffee i do like
three or four cups of coffee in the
morning that are
grinded and brewed it's not for me but
it's nice to have it in the house
same way yeah
she likes that and i'm a hot coffee man
i don't i will never do iced coffee me
neither unless what is that unless it's
like my fourth cup of the day and i just
want to mix it up sure but i'm no i'm
hot cause coffee is meant to be uh it's
meant to be consumed hot i think i think
so too but iced coffee is a big hit
i do it when i need to get caffeinated
in a rush
cause i can't like chug a hot coffee no
you can't but all uh
i mean that causes a lawsuit
in the 90s remember that with a dumb
[ __ ] thing that was a big deal like
coffee was hot i know that was your
wedding at the end exactly that was the
beginning of the litigious [ __ ] oh
man i remember geraldo had a bit about
like how people blame people get fat as
[ __ ]
and they blame mcdonald's
he's like can you imagine waddling into
a courtroom and going look at what they
did to me ah that's great that's good
yeah we need him back yeah he's the best
it just comedy just keeps things in
reality which is nice
dude
coffee should be always
you should always i remember was at a
bar once pj clark's east side classic
bartender this guy doug was like the
legendary bartender there i remember
someone asked for a red bull in there i
just overheard him say we don't do red
bull here
we do hot coffee and that's it and i was
like that's [ __ ] cool that's badass
hell yeah red bull as we're drinking
pretty effeminate looking drinks here
with a raspberry
i know jesus i only do hot coffee and
drinks with raspberries yeah i gotta i
got a placenta on ice here
that's what we're calling this episode
by the way matt placenta on ice the
worst ice capade show of all time by the
way man starring brian boytano
placenta on ice oh
man did you see i tonya oh it's great
that was a great movie great movie
michael robbie's a beast uh what's her
name jenny allison janney killer i love
her man so good two rules yeah that was
a fun movie who who did that who
directed it also that guy sebastian stan
who was one of the avenger guys but he's
crazy abusive boyfriend oh yeah he's
great it's like the soundtrack rocked it
was like it was done at a fast pace like
the way yeah the way like thank you for
smoking was done it was like bam bam bam
like with a great killer
like chicago was on the soundtrack
super [ __ ] it was all great tunes did
you that this is what's great about
documentaries like i watched eye tanya
was awesome it was great well done movie
but then you watch the documentary and
you're like this is the real [ __ ] yeah
this and now we're getting like the
[ __ ] she sucks a little more than you
think exactly that's the thing i heard
her on a i heard her on a podcast and i
was like ah she's but she kind of sucks
this has been glammed up a little bit
yeah you know what it makes me think of
did you see the woodstock documentary on
which 99 it's it's tough it's well done
but it's like you know white men have a
problem and they're angry whatever but
there's one point where cr kid rock goes
you know it's the mid 90s so kidro or
it's 99 so kid rock goes i think bill
clinton's a pimp and monica lewinsky is
a [ __ ]
everybody goes yeah
you're like oh gosh that is not age well
kind of like kid rock but yeah true but
uh no but that's what that reminds me of
well monica lewinsky man is such an
incredible it's like
holy [ __ ] we blame the intern and not
and not the dude yeah who [ __ ]
whip this dick out who was president i
know like bill clinton got such an easy
he got off easy no no pun intended but
yeah you're right it's true i mean you
get why women are joining that she was a
kid i know everything was so [ __ ] up
yeah she got it hit her and she's cool
as [ __ ] she's so cool she's funny she
makes jokes she gets it and dude i saw
her i remember i saw her on the tom
green show when i was a kid and i was
just like oh [ __ ] monica lewinsky's cool
yeah like she was um funny quick
light-hearted
and she was also it's like you know what
you were a [ __ ]
bad kid you were a kid yeah
with the president and that was back
when the president was like a big deal
now the president's like all right oh my
god dude we've all experienced social
media
attacks right
nothing compares to oh my god i was a
national [ __ ] it was like 9 11. can
you imagine
twitter
i can't imagine
crazy i mean every news story women
newscasters going she sucks [ __ ] her she
should be ashamed of herself and you're
like oh jesus mob mentality before
twitter yeah that was like
uh local newscasts just [ __ ] yeah like
yeah i mean i will say this it probably
didn't help that every late night talk
show
was a man they trashed her too yeah
because it's like it becomes easy you do
want a female voice in there being like
slow down a second this dude is the
president right you know i will say
chappelle had that great bit about it
and never [ __ ] on her he was like he was
just like look she's a young woman
dealing with the president the most
famous man most powerful man on the on
the planet you know like yeah it was
it's crazy like she's of course uh gonna
be
uh what is it uh tempted by him and
i think he said the whole thing about
how bill clinton he's like i did not
have he's like i thought that was
special because he lied on t i mean i'm
butchering it it's in kill him softly
it's a great point remember the bit and
also rocks bit about how he blamed
hillary that was hilarious
she put the whole country in danger you
know what kind of man you have exactly
that was a [ __ ] smoking fornicator
yeah it's great he's like she should
have been there like i gotcha
he's pushing monica out of the way
that was killing that was a great bit
though those are the 90s that was a
really great bit isn't it funny that
we're that old now where we're like oh
man those those times were crazy and we
lived through them that chris rock album
got me in the comments me too that was
like that blew my mind how funny he was
unbelievable with social commentary like
that's one of the best hours of comedy
ever easily opened with columbine in in
in bigger and blacker he's like
that they they had six friends i don't
have six friends now that's three on
three with a half court he's like i see
a white kid i jump off the elevator like
all that [ __ ] was huge amazing amazing
and that was like when being scared of
white people was new you know i mean it
was all ahead of his time killer stuff
i'm sure you could knew in terms of like
talking about it yeah
exactly i mean i'm sure black people
were scared of white people before the
90s yeah yeah of course of course
you got uh but uh you know it's called
waylon jennings playing out the car with
the rebel flag on the roof you know and
that's a little nerve-wracking if you're
uh poc
dude poc great uh competitor to aoc
but uh she's a poc
yeah i know you know me i'm down with
opp
all right
so um
man
oh sorry we went over to the tangent
well monaco
we were on some before monica because i
was like that reminds me of kid rock
and then it was something you said and
now i'm lost
buy in bulk that's the message buying
bulk is a mess that was the wreck that
was my wreck what is your oh you got ted
lasso now give me a goddamn i got hold
on peeve will ya
okay well actually i got a peeve that
actually is related to this oh perfect
i lay it on me i have two peeves hit me
one is we're talking about like
when i this bugs me i understand that we
have male privilege but it bugs me when
people misuse
you have privilege was like okay oh okay
just use it properly sure i was talking
to someone she was you know we were
talking she said uh you know well you um
we're talking about the greyhound buses
they all used to always take greyhound
buses oh yes you know and the fun ones
and she goes oh i never have taken the
greyhound because i don't want to get
murdered that's male privilege and i was
like it's just weird to use mail i
understand i have it but to use it
about taking a greyhound bus yeah it's
more like i've never been sitting next
to a schizophrenic with a with a pocket
knife in his mouth and been like man
shit's good
[Laughter]
you know
that's so true and i ever i'm on that
bus or i was on that bus oh chinatown
bus a lot of women on the bus i mean it
was yeah i don't want to say half women
but it was 40 women sometimes it was a
woman driver like i don't know those are
the scariest of all i think it's a
little elitist to say that that is male
purpose like you won't even go on a bus
well
it's not the bus it's a long bus it's a
bad bus it's a bad bus i've done them i
mean
the new york buses i used to do those
overnight how about those double decker
buses oh been there baltimore dc you're
like oh these stink stink and that
charger never worked never worked plug
it in and out you twisted it nothing i
remember watching uh an episode of mad
men
on the on the double decker bus highest
part ever had been watched on a bus yeah
exactly that just shows you the reach of
of tv yeah that's true
otherwise it's a casino game or
angry birds on full volume by the way on
the bus i remember vomiting
in
bus bathrooms those are the worst
because you got to hold yourself still
yeah that's right that's a core that's
like a p90x core workout while you're
vomiting that's so true and that
that toilet hole wasn't big it wasn't
you were all over i was because whenever
i go pee on that bus i'm like whoa oh
but i was like who's puking in here it
was you also
also was always there was always some
sort of like motor going down and you're
like oh we just are we pulled off the
side of the road i know
every time
why are we pulled over like oh we hit a
deer you're like jesus christ so we hit
a lady or we were at mcdonald's we
everybody get mcdonald's now and then
you come back and you leave a guy
there's always a thing
buddy up we're adults come on how about
the one where uh
that story in canada the guy just fell
asleep next to a guy and he sought his
head off and everyone ran off the bus
screaming remember that [ __ ] matt you're
my oh look it up yeah a guy saw the
guy's head off while he was sleeping and
everyone just ran off the bus screaming
oh my god in canada i thought about that
[ __ ] that's why i never slept on the bus
yeah see this is where i get jealous of
people who can sleep but then you hear
this [ __ ] and you're like all right i'm
glad i'm paranoid i'm glad i'm neurotic
yeah beheaded
what seat mate canadian can we not call
them mates at that point
[Laughter]
i know also uh always wear when you hit
hit the guy next to go where you headed
i'm trying to stay alive thank you
holy [ __ ] greyhound yeah man that's bad
pr yeah 40 year old man i mean how do
you what's the process there
what you think the saw would hit the
neck and the guy would wake up and and
you know
act
and i think you're just intact yeah i
don't know man crazy maybe he was that
quick of a beheading i mean this guy
must have been isis level
that's impressive
holy [ __ ] yeah i didn't mean to bring
this to us no no i'm sorry i mean you
hope you get a free ticket after that
geez louise they would pull that [ __ ]
they would be like well we we thank you
for riding greyhound and we'd like to
offer you ten dollars off your next
yeah exactly you're like speaking of off
i just saw a guy's head
off
yeah right
holy hell that is wild did he put it in
the luggage rack
where
that's hilarious you think greyhound has
a luggage rack
no they stuck it beneath with all the
other bags there's about a six inch
shelf with that little that little
ribbon of rope that's supposed to hold
something in but yeah i've been on a
million of them and i'm with you those
buses stink stink you always get next to
the weirdo
it sucks it's always a guy who smells
weird or playing music i had a guy
facetiming once just with his like uncle
he's like yeah i know right well and the
uncle's talking i'm sitting right there
no headphones i bet right nothing no
headphones on
[ __ ]
real unbelievable you're not a person
yeah what do you do you don't deserve
like
that's when you wish a virus would take
out people like that yeah it'd be nice
when you're like oh this is who this is
survival of the fittest this is who is
unfit yes this good point is not fit for
our world people
it's amazing that your speaker
facetime's one thing it's like all right
earbuds in you're on sp you think we
want to see and hear
your full [ __ ] thing i know i love
this idea let instead of you know it
what is it pre-condition pre-existing
conditions covered people die old people
die uh unhealthy people die it'd be nice
inconsiderate people died that would be
a great i know a guy in the wuhan lab
let me get him get him on the horn
no all right
he's our first guest by the way
we just talked to him he's a martini man
he loves martini we'll get him hammered
he's throwing out crazy uh crazy we
gotta do guests at some point he's like
sars was fake i made it up um yeah i'd
love to have a get we i'm thinking roy
wood is my ideal opener really oh yeah
well first of all we got a couple of
honkies all over this factory we got
matt we got sour cues we got the beer
jew i hear you it'd be nice to get a
little a little color in here and and he
he likes uh he likes to tilt one and
he's hilarious where did he drink
i don't know that's good i think he's a
vodka man but who the hell knows
yeah he'd be great
all right let me uh wait did you give me
a pee if you did yeah the gray oh the
the privilege when it's not necessary i
unders and i preface that by saying i
understand that
such a thing exists i'm just saying
that's not a great example this is why i
won't say getting murdered getting
murdered less
is male privilege that's nice but i'm
just saying riding the bus is not a
privilege
that's all i'm saying i am saying right
that's a good point
we do i mean look i think men get
murdered more than women though do they
i wonder i would i would think i mean
we're not relationships gangs sure but
that's a choice although someone's
riding the bus i guess yeah but i think
everything's a choice at some point but
i'm just saying
right you
choose in the dating world i think women
have to worry about that yes i think and
but then you then you factor in rape and
it's like women have the edge of course
of course i mean so it's like
it's weird to say the edge speaking of
weird things that women
you know i hear you i hear in
relationships marriages it's always the
husband this potito lady obviously the
boyfriend did it it's so obvious
every true crime my girl is obsessed
with true crime it's like the husband
the boyfriend oh my god i mean the gabby
potito thing it's like it's like yeah of
course yeah he's on the lam already now
the dog the bounty hunter is on the case
yeah
hell yeah if he finds him does he get
two more n words has he earned it let's
hope let's see i don't know should be
the gift
yeah he's like please i really want it
please also uh the murder guy the
laundry is it laundry yeah andre yeah
he's doing stand-up now he's uh
on the appalachian trail
yeah he's gonna be big he's getting
tick-tock he's got a tick-tock yeah
that's the one where if when the f when
svu does an episode you know it's gonna
be called uh taking out the laundry oh
of course dirty laundry it's laundry day
yeah there's no doubt about it yeah uh
he's got a couple stains in that pile
some blood stains that's a crazy one
that his parents helped i know
i know but then also you're kind of like
they're the parents like of course they
[ __ ] help that's how it goes although
mine won't help
i love my mom i love my mom but she
turned my ass in yeah good point she'd
be like i knew it i'm like no you didn't
she's like i know but i want to be on
their side right right
did you see the the two kids who got
popped for a school shooting before they
caught them before they did it what
happened it was two kids in florida 14
13 two cute little pudgy white kids of
course give it a goog they uh they had a
their room was full of weapons rifles
ammunition 14 and 13 what the [ __ ] i
know their book bag had a schematic of
the school they had all the x's on where
the the security cameras were they had
it down there it is where's this
organization on your homework young man
aha good point yes exactly there it is
they found it they they caught him they
yelled at him but the my point is the
mom they filmed the mom on the news and
she was like i swear to god they're good
kids they would never do this and you're
like they have [ __ ] ak-47s in their
bedroom you psycho they're good they're
good kids you're the world's worst mom
exactly what's the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] this
is you know what i remember there was a
story years ago about kids who were
going to shoot up at school and george
this kid was going to shoot up at school
and uh he got stopped by his teacher
and she and he said no one loves me and
she goes i don't care if no one loves
you i love you
and uh he put the gun down he gave it to
her and he got arrested and i'm sure
he's like that [ __ ] [ __ ] lied to me
women be tripping women are [ __ ] that
did not help with women issues yeah good
point but at least she stopped the death
but that's all they need is a hug they
need a hug i mean but also what the [ __ ]
as a mom
that's on you like i used to hate my mom
for going through my [ __ ] all the time
that's a good mom good mom i feel the
same way that's a good mom to make sure
you don't have an ak-47
in your [ __ ] bedroom or whatever i
don't know anything about guns i'm a
manhattan kid you know i don't know
about guns so when you're like that's
not the name of the gun there i'm like
all right
you got me there
i don't know [ __ ] about guns right guns
freak me out
yeah no i'm with you my dad wore a suit
every day in a briefcase i was like what
a square he's part of the the machine
i'm a skateboarder i'm gonna chain
wildlife he's the man now i'm like thank
god he paid the mortgage he kept the
lights on he got groceries you know he
yelled at me when i got a detention and
i'm like thank you dad oh no my parents
were great that's the thing it's like
when you're a kid you're just angry for
no reason oh yeah my parents are so good
yes sir i mean that's like the thing
where you're just like what the [ __ ]
um and you had that you had a guy step
in right like oh my my dad yeah that's
that's the best day even more of a hero
yeah he's such a good dad i mean yeah my
dad is biological biologically not my
dad but he's my legally my dad yeah
uh yeah he's the best dad i wonder if
there's a trans joke there
you know
you know this is not your real dad but
he's my dad that's interesting he
identifies as my dad yes there you go
that's the line
you correct yeah we didn't get enough
hot water last week about that that
misfire i had on that transition well
[ __ ] uh old man cues over here is
like hey what are we doing foxy it was
like all right no no but he's it's good
to have that voice
it's good to have to be challenged
because then you're like i'm wrong it's
good it's actually good all right well
do you have a did you do a wreck oh no
did you do a peeve oh you did a peeve
yeah i didn't do a pee do a peeve all
right i'm doing a pee okay i
um
i'll do i'll do one i'll save one but
i don't know which one to do
they're both pretty solid i'll do i'll
do a couple hold on do a couple what is
this one and this this this is where
we'll lose fans here but
you ever have we've lost plenty
you ever have the friend or the random
guy you meet and he's got a ton of [ __ ]
on his teeth like
crazy amounts of food where you're like
look nobody likes brushing their teeth i
get it but i know you man you're not
like a
hobo you got a ton of plaque like orange
goo on your teeth wow what are we doing
here have you seen this
no i guess i don't notice i don't look
for it yeah
but that's uh
interesting so he just doesn't brush you
think i think it's it's it's disturbing
like look i'll i'll i'll forget to brush
i'm like oh it's 6 p.m i should brush
but it's like this crazy
you can just see like orangey weird
plaquey kind of [ __ ] on someone's teeth
where you're like
dude you're like a you have a job you're
a established citizen you have a
girlfriend or a wife like what's going
on here that's her job
maybe you know but also i'll say this uh
dentists came out of the gate a little
too hard with the brushing after every
meal i grew americans we eat like six
meals a day good point you gotta [ __ ]
you gotta hit us with you gotta hit us
with twice a day
twice a day is fair or before an
important
thing yeah
we all brush before an important thing
just because at a routine you're like
i'm gonna shower
it's kind of connected to the shower
yeah it is i do it in the shower it's a
refresh you can rush in the shower i
brush in the shower because it's a it's
a one and done i don't have to do a
brush and a shower dude i'll tell you
what's [ __ ] good you ever just drink
in the shower oh
a cocktail in the shower is [ __ ] nice
cocktail what i'll have a beer i've
never had a cocktail well you don't have
a shaker at home you're an adult i do
have a shaker but i've never thought
like hold on i'm getting in the chicken
in this thing i make it i get in the
shower then i reach outside and i grab a
cocktail i'm like this is [ __ ] nice
i'm on board with the drinkie in the
shower i've never thought of a cocktail
i've had a beer it's in a can it's
contained i don't know this is this is
blowing my mind well here's what you was
up there with
was the other one [ __ ] in the butt oh
jizzy in your hand
well i stand by that one i'm going green
and i hope the hello tushy people come
around on me yeah jizz in my hand i
shoot it into the [ __ ] sink you got
to get a bidet on that hand there you go
speaking of spider-man you're going to
start sticking hello handy
we uh you know
yeah the drink is nice because you duck
your head out of the shower you get a
cocktail it's kind of a nice way to
start the night interesting interesting
i've never done a cocktail not a beer
beer is good
uh wine is good it's hard to do wine by
yourself because then you have to commit
to the bottle that's true you get the
cork i don't like cork and i have it but
it's like we made a choice
something about like a negroni or a
manhattan when you're just like chilling
the shower like that's oh vodka's nice
too i i see a lot of drinkers at our
shows and i've noticed that like
we get a lot of professional drinkers we
really do yeah so i notice i'll talk to
people what they're drinking sometimes
and a lot of people would be doing like
a vodka
with like a splash of soda i'm like
that's a professional alcohol it's a pro
maybe a slice of lemon or something that
that guy knows what he's doing or gail i
completely i mean don't get me wrong we
get a couple animals out there as well
sure but i don't like long island iced
tea drunks no
you're not you're not drinkers you're
you're trying to escape too quickly yes
you know
this is like a prison break you don't
just run out the front door there's an
art yes you have to work your way up you
dig a hole you get a crew
yeah you know you don't just run or
you're gonna get shot well said yes it's
exactly like a heist you could go in
with a gun and put it on the guy's
temple and take all the money but you're
gonna get caught if you put a whole gang
together with a van and an escape route
and a talker and a muscle you're good
and that's what this is yeah this is a
nice escape
good drink great
i'm pretty nice and buzzed i know i know
we gotta it's only four
we got a long night ahead of us we got
shows yeah um but comedy juice
oh that's a fun show that's a fun one
are you doing a longer set or the same
just regularly tell milhouse i said hi
he's a good guy oh yeah he's a good dude
um oh oh so much funny that his name is
milhouse i know and he looks he's little
with glasses it's perfect but so he's i
always say he's uh he's um
he's a good dude
bizarro veter
[ __ ] i'm with vitor this weekend in st
louis oh nice helium yeah yeah that'll
be fun
st louis has about a uh uh
it's a 100 feet of good [ __ ] there's
like cool restaurants there's there's
old bars i mean if people came out of
there it's like talk about strangers
nicki glazer hilarious i think greg
warren might be from there
he's back there too but then it's like
miles davis and all these other guys
like jb smoove like it's like james
brown maybe there's other people were
forgetting yeah yeah st louis is like
this cedric the entertainer i think is
from there it's like this crazy bastion
of talent because it's such a rough city
and i think that that struggle breeds
quality lewis is brutal i mean i
remember doing a gig and wow jenna
fisher john hamm
john hamm oh and the woman from uh
unbreakable kimmy schmidt too yeah she's
great ellie kemper yeah she's right
there
andy cohn interesting andy conan just
seems so new york that's funny
um yeah you know uh i remember doing
that old valley park funny bone you ever
do that one mm-hmm that one was a [ __ ]
hole talk about a a mom and poppy like
i don't know i like that room i feel
like it was fine but it wasn't like an
easy room no it was i mean look i'm down
for a road room man
it was in between a gun shop and a bird
store
it's a weird energy right here that's
all i'm saying completely weird energy
but i will say i did that club years ago
and the uh the waitress was this lady
named like flo she had a big beehive
hairdo blonde lady smoking she's like i
saw seinfeld in 78. he sucked
he sucked then he sucks now i'm like i
don't know he's pretty great and she's
like ah [ __ ] him he sucks he's not he's
got no edge i'm like all right all right
and his dick doesn't work neither like
jesus there's always something behind it
but that's interesting man those clubs
those waitresses yeah yeah everything
those funny bone waitresses in
um st louis it's hilarious they're just
still cigarettes i know how the [ __ ]
does that happen until like three years
ago but that's that's a throwback it's
kind of funny it's like this time
machine you go into and you're like oh
this is so cool and everybody's been
through here like i did providence the
bartender becky has been there for 20
years and we got drunk with her one
night and we just picked her brain and
she's like a normal regular civilian
lady but she was like i saw bill bird
like 95
and this and that and you're like wow
and she's like he struggled a little bit
but now he's like one of my favorites
and blah blah blah and you're like oh my
god it makes you realize like he's hot
tiny club in providence you don't say
like [ __ ] happens well yeah of course
she wasn't [ __ ] on him how do you
feel about comedians using the term
civilian about non-comedians
because you just did it i just did it
yeah how do you feel about that well i
do think we're a species where we're a
weird group and we're different but do
you think we're making them the species
when we do that
maybe but
i'm not i've worked in the uh the
cubicles i've worked in weight waitering
i've worked in restaurants i've been on
the other side yeah for years and it's
different
i meet comedians i hang out with
comedians and you start you start
noticing you're dating comedian you
start noticing like we gotta stick
together we're different
we are we are just married to one we're
all uh weirdos you know that's yeah of
course i mean we're
the booze is kicking in folks for sure
i'm definitely feeling it this is the
part of the episode where you're like oh
[ __ ] uh sam and mark might be drunk
well hey it's the name of the game but
um yeah man it's
there's something about this life where
it's just like but it's our brain i
think our brains are different like
chris rock has that funny thing where he
saw seinfeld at a met gala kind of thing
and he was like oh comedian right we
could be real that's his own fault for
going to a mecca of course i agreed like
why the [ __ ] are you with the mech
gallery you're chris rock i know go
there but go there at your own risk like
you can't you can't be like
wow i'm annoyed the people here suck
you're at the met gala dude
it's like what what do you expect but
sometimes you have to go i don't know
maybe his wife wanted to go whatever it
is sure but it's my point is like we see
each other we're like oh i can be real i
can be honest like and i think that's
why people like comedians because we're
weird we're different we have to say
these things that maybe they're thinking
and they're talking you absolutely have
a hint of autism sure
there's nothing and i and i mean that
completely respectfully there's
something about you where you can't i've
never i don't have any other friend like
you well you can't resist saying the
most [ __ ] up thing possible and it's
ruined my life up till now now i'm
finally capitalizing i mean high school
jobs parents family whatever it is dates
brutal look at norm you put norm on the
view
it's a whole different show he's
he's
rousing it up the whole thing's shaken
up and that's what we like we like a bit
of chaos yes
there's the marx brothers a little bit
of anarchy what was that what was that
short story was i think it's like
bartleby the scribner you know what i'm
talking about matt look it up i've never
heard of that well
it's a guy
driven crazy by a guy just repeatedly
saying i'd prefer not to
everything he says i say i prefer not to
is that isn't that it yeah
that's fun groucho marx is a funny song
hello i must be going which is like i
got in i got out and i completely relate
to that yeah you know how it is you go
to a party or a dinner party or it's
like you make one joke they hate it
you're like what am i doing here these
aren't my people
yeah it's tough it's tough everything
you say you ever do a corporate and they
go have dinner with us
and you're like dinner
i'm a comedian i do the show it's gonna
cut that's gonna cost extra of course
i'm a quiet weirdo and then you're
putting the spotlight on you're quiet
until you're around someone that you
feel comfortable with yes you're not
quite around me no no i've never thought
yeah you're a comedian i've never
thought you were quiet but then i yeah
i've seen you in in places where you're
not yeah where you don't feel
comfortable it's tough it's tough yeah
yeah and you're the i feel like you're
the same way i'm not saying you're a
loud guy but you you have you have your
comfort levels yeah i think i'm
i think i can be loud and silly and of
course but it it you know like you've
seen that side of me but that side of me
doesn't come out i love that side of you
but that side doesn't come out easily
right it takes it takes some you know
grease and whatever yeah yeah but you
gotta admit that's a fun side i'm having
fun all right
yeah that's tough i know things things
are weird now cause because we're all on
camera all the time we're all on a mic
all the time but like isn't that weird
it's weird it's like
it is a little
crazy that people can just kind of
record you i know that part sucks i mean
because we just be friends sometimes and
you're kind of like oh [ __ ] all right
yeah
yeah that is
it's funny like
you don't know
when it's appropriate like with friends
you're kind of like all right we can do
it but like there is a limit to it where
you're kind of like all right i just
want to like hang out of course yeah i
have a friend who's a comic we both know
black guy who's like we make horrific
jokes in the green room and if we did
any of that in public we would both be
in trouble he'd be in trouble with the
black community i'd be in trouble with
everyone else and in the black community
and the black community
and but we're like yeah it's so silly
we're all gonna die one day we're
friends we know each other we like jokes
you know this is just a blip on the roof
it's a time share
oh yeah actually accordingly
right i mean i guess so
man
yeah i was on the i was on a plane the
other day and it's like you're so
grateful when people are cool i was on
it it was like a really cool flight
attendant the guy was such a sweetheart
and it's like man you're just so
that job to be cool right now yeah so
much so you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm
gonna do a [ __ ] i'm gonna do a toast
to anyone in the customer service game
right now
particularly flight attendants because
i'm around them so much
if you're a flight attendant right now
you're dealing with so much [ __ ]
like an astronomical amount of [ __ ]
yeah people are acting out against you
as if it's your [ __ ] design yeah
this guy was so nice he could see i you
know i have a bad neck and he could see
me stretching by the door and he goes i
can see her in pain anything and i
wasn't asking for that i was literally
in my corner trying not to be noticed
and he was like anything i can do let me
know wow and you know i asked for a
swedish massage and uh no
wow but that's rare nowadays especially
in customer service i'll say another
thing this is [ __ ] hilarious i i got
it's not really it's a coincidence i
don't like when people do that either
but i i got to do everything you hate i
got them i know i i don't like myself
that's the end of it same i uh i got a
massage in austin because you know i was
in horrible pain and my masseur a guy
named stan an austin great guy
he
when he's done he goes i'm gonna i'm
coming to your show tomorrow night
and i was like i was grateful he didn't
say till the end because i wouldn't have
been able to relax exactly smart guy
but uh he was a really nice guy and he
was great massage therapist uh form and
function and austin shout uh toast to
that to you guys you guys are great hell
yeah that is a nice touch and the fact
that he was aware of that makes you like
it more and you're like oh we can even
hang out probably because you get it the
guys who you walk in
santa real oh my god we might be drunk
get on the massage table oh you want to
do a shot you're like what are you crazy
i hate you already you want to hang out
with me you're nuts this is why the
people that listen to this podcast are
cool and this is why we don't deal with
those people a lot yeah most of people
at our shows are pretty cool pretty cool
we got a good fan base we got good
crowds we got comedy fans they love it
they get it i've had guys come up and go
hey comedy and they're on the other side
of the street i'm like oh hey they're
like i'm not going to bother you you're
good i'm like all right that guy gets it
we're all people they're all people
we're all people i met larry david at
schumer's wedding i'm so upset i wasn't
at that point
i would have been the private jet with
you i had was the host of an msg show at
the time and i couldn't get off i was
control i was contractually obligated of
course to shoot episodes for this
network i would have been on a private
jet with you going to amy schumer's
wedding i was so bummed i wasn't there i
love amy i was pretty go i mean i was
hobnobbing it was me and kyle dunnigan
just like
you know
based in the corner there and then it
was like nikki glazer and then seth
meyers and judd apatow and bridget
everett it was like such a fun group uh
john early killed it by the way but that
guy is like
talent that guy
he like oozes
hilarity there he does he's almost like
a martin short he is like
that guy's pure funny pure funny pure
talent confident i don't know how he
does it because we're writers i mean
this guy is just like
funny it's it's just coming out of him
whatever but yeah i know he is like you
could put him anywhere and he'll he's on
tim robinson's new season he's on um
search parties great he's that guy is
incredible incredible incredible
but uh yeah also schumer had the best
joke um i've told this before but i was
so impressed because they're doing the
vows it's we're on malibu it's a
beautiful beach view i don't know how
much i'm supposed to be telling but
the husband chris does this like
beautiful vows and like heartfelt
whatever you know
tugging the heartstrings like wow he
really loves her and then she goes uh
i'm gonna plug my dates and it [ __ ]
killed it was so perfect the tension was
cut because he was so serious i mean it
was gold wow and that was the wedding
you know like that that was just the
beginning of the wedding yeah but either
way
uh
i wasn't there i love amy that was that
was a bummer i remember being like i
knew it would be us in a private jet and
that would have been [ __ ] hilarious
in of itself yeah what was great about
the jet she got like a jumbo for the for
the ride out you know cross country jet
so you got these snl comedian types and
me and rachel and rachel's husband and
all these people rachel feinstein and
bridget everett and all these people and
then amy's long island high school and
eighth grade public school friends and
they're [ __ ] going we're on a [ __ ] ah
they're doing shots they're [ __ ]
rolling dice and all this [ __ ] they're
drinking 40s and and high-fiving each
other to blair and uh you know bruce
springsteen
and all the snlp were like oh [ __ ] and
they're all you know in their headphones
and phones and everything
it was fun to see that that those two
worlds which is kind of
rep describes amy perfectly she's both
of those she's everything yeah she's
everything yeah yeah so that was fun but
uh and she's so loyal to her oh so loyal
so loyal she gets [ __ ] but man no one no
one more loyal than than the shum but
either way my point is she is she's a
real friend yes yes i mean she gave us
both specials for christ's sake amy
schumer produced when no one would give
mark or myself a special amy schumer
produced both our [ __ ] specials how
did she offer you
the special what'd she say crazy uh
it never came up and i remember we were
in a van you know you get into a van you
leave a hotel you get into a van you go
to the gig or the the venue some giant
arena and she goes you know what i think
i'm going to produce your special and i
was like
i was in the back of the van you always
want to be out of the way as the opener
you know and i was like yeah
and i remember my brain was just like oh
my god
and then that was when i that was when
she planted the seed and then you know
the steps go from there and then it's a
year-long process but that was it that's
awesome you
we were like doing a gig in uh
in philly
and we were we were riding back on a
helicopter it's a very relatable story
and
we just done the arena in philly i think
was wells fargo wow amazing dude it's
insane
um wow what was like 14 000 people or
something inside
couldn't have been more fun wow there
was supposed to be another opener where
there wasn't so i got to do 25 minutes
for an arena and i was just [ __ ] ham
having a great time was it was it just
you was the band there no there's no
band oh wow so just me and uh
super fun and she we're in the hell it
was me amy and amy's mom and amy's mom
quoted a joke of mine that she liked and
amy was like oh yeah i really like that
joke uh the joke was you women are
amazing because you can fake an orgasm
but not a good mood great job that was a
big one in arenas that was like because
it was like a one-liner that would kill
in a big venue you'd be like boom all
right and it's a slow like that
yeah right they all get it in a big
venue when it rolls back yes and she was
like yeah i really like that joke she
goes yeah would you want me to produce
your special and i was she was like
think on it and i was kind of like
[ __ ] to make my decision let's do
this yeah thank you but uh yeah she
would but yeah i remember being like wow
that's pretty cool that's amazing so
yeah uh [ __ ] [ __ ] man i got i gotta
sip left and you let me ah there you go
toast to her toes to amy she gets a lot
of [ __ ] but they don't know her you
don't know her you don't know what she's
like and she's also made
so much great [ __ ] i know and open for a
tell for years by the way
so what is that wreck
the uh her book is great oh yeah inside
amy schumer i mean so much emmy
award-winning jewelry dreifus was great
on that you know donegan metzger all
these people
so much great killer stuff yeah
but you know the internet is
mean and terrifying and uh
well they go after us too right i mean
they're off to everybody yeah that's how
it goes i mean you go after who's
successful i mean it's human nature
for sure anyone at the top it's like
that's why i don't want to be at the top
top sucks i like the bottom
i'm a bottom but my point was i met
larry david
and it was the toughest moment of my
life because he's like my ultimate hero
the show seinfeld changed my life he's
my guy he's the funniest guy i love curb
i love his stand-up i just think he's
the he's like
my guy whatever it is
amy i'm i'm like dancing at a wedding
about like 20 cocktails deep the blazers
off he's sitting at a table you can tell
he's miserable he's like i just want to
go home and
she goes
oh i'm she's standing there i'm standing
he's sitting at a table and she goes
mark you got to meet larry and in my
head i'm going
of course i've been i've been clocking
him the whole night following him
watching him with one eye you know and
she's like you got to meet larry and i'm
like oh hey larry he goes hey and he
goes you're comedian i go yeah he goes i
yeah i can tell you're a comedian all
right
and i was like yeah yeah and that was it
i left it at that no one thank you
whatever that's how you do but it took
everything i had i wanted to blow him i
wanted to make out with him i wanted to
sit on his lap but it was the hardest
thing i've ever done but i didn't do it
yeah but that but i bet he likes you
better well he probably doesn't remember
me yeah but you don't want that dude to
remember you if he remembers you you
[ __ ] up royally good point good point
you know yeah yeah but it it hurt i mean
even you know me i can't contain and i
wanted to just go that's your whole
thing yeah that's my whole thing and i
contained because it was him the king he
is the king ah
even norm i met and i contained i wanted
to just pull up harry david is something
else so it's like
to go from seinfeld to curb is [ __ ]
insane i know and he did stand up in the
70s and he knew everybody did fridays i
mean and the guy hated himself and he
was about to be homeless i mean he's got
he's got so many things that i relate to
and just he's just such a genius and he
never caved and he never changed the
show is irreverent and weird and funny
and dark the blacks i mean everything is
so
he's like to me he's almost keeping
comedy alive and he's on hbo and
everybody respects him ah i love it i do
i do agree with you like there's
something about larry that he keeps it
so [ __ ] real and the fact that he's
like
almost the villain in some episodes
the fact that he like will just be an
[ __ ] like that's important for comedy
completely completely and
when they did snl the big 40 years or
whatever it was snl eddie murphy's there
all this [ __ ] and then they cut to larry
david and they go what do you think
larry goes
i just want to go home
i hate being here like he's so true to
his character seinfeld said he's like
the only guy i've never seen change with
success everybody gets 20 million they
just become different he's like i've
never seen a guy not change at all he's
from sheepshead bay grew up in brooklyn
in a tiny apartment with a jewish family
and he's just still that guy deep down i
love it he was a he drove a cab
wow that's [ __ ] hilarious to picture
your favor driving a cab i'm such a fan
he did 60 minutes one one night and i
had to watch it and they went to his old
apartment in brooklyn
like he literally went there and they
knock on the door and you know some like
loacian family some crazy ethnicity
answered the door and they're like hello
and they didn't speak english and he was
like can we come in here and they were
like oh duh you know it was great
and they went in he's like this is my
room the room was smaller than this room
he's like my fam my grandmother lived up
to new york though you know exactly it
was amazing he's the real deal
i love it he got in trouble for a 911 or
a holocaust joke on snl he did the snl
monologue and the press like hounded him
about it like because it was like real
pc time and everything he was like when
was this this is probably like four
whenever he did snl four years ago five
years ago so funny it's like you know
how you can avoid this [ __ ] you could
just say
i don't care that's what he did you
think larry you do you think larry david
thinks 911 was funny of course not so
then shut the [ __ ] up stop making a
non-stop like you know what man it was
the holocaust i was 911. i shouldn't say
that but either way he's a jew exactly
you know
it's just so it's a bummer you know and
it's also a guy who doesn't take cheap
jokes he's so thoughtful so that's what
really bugs me you know where
sometimes i'll i'll see the overkill
with the 911 never forget and like i'm a
new yorker i was here that day i
remember lining up to donate blood i
remember the whole thing and like
clearly
a 911 joke in poor taste i'm not gonna
like i'm a new yorker i'm just like it's
not my thing yeah but i'm also not gonna
be like you don't deserve
to have the floor like it's just really
kind of yeah it bugs me so it's strange
um it's this weird guillotine society
we're creating it also it's like you've
built up a reputation as one of the best
comics
maybe you just chill the [ __ ] out when
when a joke doesn't land for you
right agree right it's like this dude
has built up a resume as
a legend so it's like
maybe he was off maybe you were off
what's more likely right
maybe you were both off who gives a [ __ ]
move on yeah they just need a story so
that's the other thing it's like if you
give and go man i really [ __ ] up back
there or you could say
yeah no not every joke is for every
person of course so and i'm a comedian i
make jokes like this one happened to hit
you in your soft spot i joined the club
i mean if we did that with everyone we
wouldn't have any jokes
you know if everybody everybody's been
through [ __ ] people are offended by
seinfeld jokes that should tell you
everything you need to know it's like
well not every joke's for everyone yeah
of course of course and and you're fine
you're still there you're alive you're
not hurt you're you're good no one ever
no one ever died from a joke
how'd your grandpa die no one how'd your
grandpa die they [ __ ] they joked him
to death yeah
there was a couple of jokes about uh
about 9 11. he just fell to the floor
pollock
oh [ __ ]
i know but it's like jackass
has like repercussions the new trailer
is amazing by the way i can't wait to
watch it but jackass is like
jokes but it's pranky it's whatever or
borat is pranky i'm like to me that's
way worse things are happening to people
this is a joke about a school shooting
i'm not
shooting any kid these are things that
are happening people like you're
dropping a bucket of jizz on a guy or
whatever like
that i get being mad about but this is a
this is letters in a certain order in a
sentence to illicit laughter i don't
know the whole thing is very strange but
my point is larry david
got in trouble for a holocaust joke and
they they questioned me and he went wha
and that was the end of it and i was
like yeah
that's my point
you want what i'm a jew from brooklyn i
can't make a joke what are you crazy
like that that's what you said that's
kind of my reaction to it it's just like
wait you know you didn't like eating
like
here's the thing i have over stepped on
stage and been like ah [ __ ] i think i
overstepped like in a way in a way that
made me feel bad if it makes me feel bad
yeah then i'm gonna say i should i
shouldn't have said that but otherwise i
don't get because i don't relate to
comics who are like i'll never apologize
i'm never going to be like groveling but
i will be like that wasn't really right
i'll say it like that wasn't really me
that's kind of where i'll be like
totally but i'll never be like
be like oh please governor
i'll do anything i'll suck your dick
yeah please hat in hand no but i have
said so i've been like yeah i'm not
happy with what you just said like i'm
i'm displeased with myself but here's
the scale that's why i don't need you to
[ __ ] come after me because i'm
displeased with myself already well you
have a conscience and you're of a soul
you're a human being but here's the
scary part you say that thing where
you're like i didn't like i didn't even
like that but that's recorded and now
that's out there on youtube recording
recorded oh and so you're like [ __ ] that
thing i
felt bad about saying even me felt bad
about is now out there that's scary [ __ ]
i would just probably say
i don't think it's that scary because
i'm not like trying to get anything i'm
just making my own [ __ ] so i'd probably
just say you know uh hey you know
i didn't like that joke i know you're
thinking rationally like this is this is
not how it goes i mean the mob attacks
and they swore i don't want them as fans
those people that are attacking me they
can go [ __ ] themselves i don't want
people that would just come after me
over a joke
as fans
i agree because i would say look at my
entire body of work i have multiple
albums out there would just say yeah not
not everything is uh perfect i think i'm
i'm pretty consistent with should i i
release myself right right
here here no i i mean i'm not like you
can't you can't it's a bummer but
whenever anyone else controls the
narrative then it's [ __ ] like i'm
not just talking about them releasing
your [ __ ]
you know without consent i would say
look at any show like
uh america's got talent or last comic
when they control the narrative
it's [ __ ] bad it's not it's bad
that's why we control it because
we don't trust them so it's like
i just don't trust other people to
release our [ __ ]
sure yeah i'm with you on that i'm just
saying it's a this is the thing with
canceling or whatever you want to call
it is people go
louie's fine he's fine i'm like
shane gillis is fine i'm like the guy's
miserable he's depressed he wants to
kill himself
yeah he's got a couple bucks or yeah he
made a million views on his special but
he's sad
for the people who care about compassion
and people's feelings like this guy
might kill himself shane yeah i'm not i
mean he won't kill himself he's doing
great but i'm just saying like he was
doing bad what the hell well he went
through hell he's over it now but he
went through hell shane is a is a nice
guy i think and hilarious and i i think
shane um
well that it begs the question what does
to cancel mean right yeah well yeah it's
like of course is it a scarlet letter
that's pretty upsetting too
is it when you're like when people say
they're doing fine it's like i hate them
like
how do you know well they're not
homeless do you want do you want to do
you want to i know exactly where does it
end can you kill
yeah i mean
do you want like a documented letter
from a therapist i i don't understand
doing fine no one knows how anyone's
doing
exactly but they say that they go he's
fine like how do you know well they're
measuring it by finances
that's but then the same people will say
money doesn't buy happiness exactly
exactly i mean i also you know
for me it's kind of like a scarlet
letter it's kind of like right right
i think you know shane in that video i i
you know i don't remember it much but
it's like i think he was kind of the guy
just the other guy was doing the talking
really right and shane was doing an
impersonation i mean we don't think we
don't have to break down this [ __ ] yeah
but i mean shane is as far as i know a
pretty a pretty solid guy and a funny
guy yeah i i do i don't like any of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] i
i don't this is what happens mark you
know tonight he's [ __ ] down drinks
you turn it into a whole thing you know
uh we still need to do a bit
what we still need to do a bit we're
we're 20 20 i think we're four hours in
here
uh matt's already changed shirts he's
showered he went home he came back matt
speaking of louis matt is masturbating
back
thank you we'll put that on the patreon
here's my idea i don't know if i
messaged you this but there's a thought
i had
um it's about really it's a relationship
jokes how like women will hold in farts
and uh like sometimes they're holding
farce for like a year in a relationship
you know yeah you know they do have
farts but they've never done that with
feelings
that's such a great premise like i
prefer the farts yes yes like uh the
fargs pass in 30 seconds farts never
lead to real fights you never have
someone pass gas
and then you fight for five hours right
like although in both cases she might
say i'd like some space
something there there's a lot there like
yeah a woman in a restaurant like a
girlfriend will make a scene but then
she'll hide a fart you're like this is
way worse right this is way worse i've
never had you fart and been like are we
still together yeah yeah
exactly
yeah and also a fart will it will
dissipate like you don't have to come up
with this perfect line to get rid of a
fart the fart will go away no matter
what if you're fighting with a girl you
gotta like come up with a thing and
change how you're acting you know yeah
no one's ever farted but like a guy's
ever been like i gotta clean more
you know or i gotta i gotta go back to
college or whatever well you know what's
funny like as guys we come up around
farts as women you come up around
feelings we're comfortable with the
farts you're comfortable with the
feelings that's big that's big
i've had guys pin me down and fart in my
face yeah i've never heard a guy pin me
down and been like my dad never loved me
yeah that's great there's something
there that would have been a better
friendship maybe we could have gotten to
the bottom of something instead i just
got your bottom
all right but uh no that's big that's a
bit that's a real
pre-classic like something's cooking
there
what do you got i mean that's a uh the
what was the one with the you just said
it
uh they can't hide their feeling but
they can hide their
whatever
fake and orgasm that was it that's it
you can fake an orgasm but you can't
fake a good mood that's a this is a this
is a precursor that's an oldie yeah this
is this is this is going to be a biggie
this fart thing
one of there's a dutch oven how many
comedy is so silly where it's like that
fart bit that's gonna be big for you
this is like it's funny like we talk
about jokes like businessmen are like
that account that's going to change your
life this fart bit could turn things
around for you oh yeah you're right i
would put stock in that fart bin i'm
buying it is that is that optional
what do they call when the thing goes
public that's a term
all right we don't know anything about
money what uh what do you got all right
all right [ __ ] i got a couple ideas here
uh now tell me where you at on this one
because this is a silly idea and it
it's hitting but i can't figure out
where to go with it hit me that's what's
good about you you can figure out where
to go with it well i don't say that yeah
let's see okay okay
so i was at a me and a friend went to a
thrift store just [ __ ] around well
let's pop into here and i saw a used
blowup doll a used deflated blow-up doll
and my friend was like
this is so gross some guy defiled this
thing like how who would buy this is
horrific who would use this now and i
was like well what about your wife
and he was like what do you mean and i'm
like well
this has only been with one person any
normal woman has been with you know over
10 guys this is actually less
experienced than any woman you've ever
been with
in a weird way this is cleaner than any
lady
no it's interesting which i know comes
off offensive but i'm not wrong
which i like in comedy
yeah i say the one difference with his
wife is uh i don't see the other guys
staying still on her
that's true that's true
yeah and you can clean this thing you
can't be like can i get you a drink in
the shower
you know
um i know the cleanliness thing is is a
factor because a woman can shower and
whatever go to a hospital but this also
i didn't meet my ex-wife or i didn't i
didn't get her at a thrift store
that too but tinder let's be honest it's
pretty thrifty yeah tinder is a thrift
store yeah that's a nick griffin joke oh
is it what did you say he just says uh
do you ever feel like you know these
dating apps are a thrift store it's like
ah that's been that's too used that
one's
whatever i i'm butchering it but a
little wrinkled of course he [ __ ] got
there nick
guys if you don't know nick griffin oh
yeah
one of the best ever youtube is uh late
night sets
follow him on uh instagram he posts
great clips all the time great clips
yeah that's just the bit and i like it
because it's
it's one of those bits where you're like
he's not wrong but it feels dicey i
don't know the guy who used to [ __ ] that
doll
uh but you don't know every guy who did
[ __ ] you know you know their names
i don't i don't know i know your ex's na
ex-boyfriend or your girlfriend's ex she
was in high school in another city i
don't know you know at least a couple
maybe a couple but all right we how many
of those thrift uh how many of those it
was one it was one
i don't know his name but it was one guy
that's my point uh-huh you don't know
that guy he don't know what he did for a
living that's true
that's true
i mean he cleaned up enough to you don't
know where he went
exactly he's doing better than me
yeah because i bought it yeah
i bought the doll but no my point is uh
maybe it's nothing but i like the idea
of the fact that this doll has only been
with one guy and you're judging it
you're judging this doll this doll
would you buy the doll no
but i'm already i got a lady that's a
funny way to wrap it uh-huh you say you
defend the doll you defend you go yeah i
mean i'm not touching that thing right
if you say it's on this it's a
i don't i want nothing to do with it
though right i would i would just
because that's funny too i thought it'd
be funny to say i bought it but you
might be right it's funny to say i
didn't buy it
yeah i mean i'm not a weirdo but uh
i mean i'm never gonna buy i've never
had a blow up to all my life well who
wants a blow it's weird to get a blow up
doll when there are sex robots now
that's true that's your thing that's
like buying a [ __ ] black and white tv
now it's like getting a vcr they've got
3d tvs you're like no no no right i'm a
radio man
[Laughter]
you don't want itunes nah i like fm
you're right that's like being in the
radio now right yeah the blow up though
that's why i got rid of it probably he
probably got a sex robot that could be
something sex robots i i tried a bit the
other night about sex robots about how
one said i said just like the real thing
because that's what you want you want
you you want to [ __ ] it you want to [ __ ]
a sex robot and the second you're done
they're like i'm glad you came i didn't
but
were you in me yeah i had no idea i'm
glad it was good for you
oh yeah been there
but all right is it should i work on
this or yeah yeah absolutely okay okay i
like that it's like um
i like that the angle is defending the
doll i'm defending the doll the doll's
been with one guy and you're [ __ ] on
it
yeah
the the doll has been with one guy
this
your wife your sister every woman has
been with more than one guy not saying
that's bad i'm just saying that's normal
so you can't judge the doll the doll is
actually
you know an update it's a weird thing to
buy second hand of course a woman should
have mileage on her a doll it's weird
it's weird any doll
like a stuffed animal that you cuddle
find a stuffed animal that you [ __ ]
i want to see i want to see a sheet
right a teddy bear is one thing right a
sex doll it's kind of like even a teddy
bear out at a thrift store is weird yeah
it's like a [ __ ] broken home yeah
look i don't want i don't want the
oliver twist teddy doll thank you very
much yeah like how much of a deadbeat
parent are you where you're like i got
my stuff oh good good dad well it was a
second hand like jesus somebody loved
that thing and gave it up and then you
reuse the love
yikes
yeah it's like you're a good parent
because you're getting your kid toys but
you're you're getting them at a [ __ ]
discount rate
yeah yeah that is bad that could be part
of it there's something there that's not
bad there's something all right all
right all right we got we got something
i'll be noodling this in
wisconsin this weekend yeah this comes
out sunday right well then that
weekend's over oh the next one okay so
where are you going to be rochester baby
it's a good club carlson yeah classic
good room again good people too yeah
good people salt of the earth it's one
of those towns it was like we had bow
shalom we had kodak or whatever the [ __ ]
that guy killed himself did he yeah look
at that right i'm right on that yeah he
knows that [ __ ] wow that's matt peters
[ __ ] uh
it's a rochester claim defense oh yeah
that's right wow he killed him that's a
photo up he killed himself because he
said he was done
i did everything i wanted to do oh i
respect that i went to the museum a lot
as a kid
just like just like one of those
pictures click finish yeah that's it
good yeah now you develop it i'll be on
the sidewalk what do you do jump off a
building suicide uh gun in the mouth
gunshot woo
man wow ironically they took a photo of
that body with kodak film yeah let's be
honest he did it bill cosby was a kodak
guy yeah they sponsored him jello a
couple places damn yeah kodak was huge
huge
it was the film that's funny it's like
if you're like don draper you're like we
booked the kodak account oh
and then by the time don draper is an
old man he's like we need to get out of
this kodak thing yeah
making no money nothing bowshan loam
kodak xerox fell through a lot of these
anything facts related
yeah anything uh tangible it's all
digital now
so you're rochester where else you got
coming up rochester boston new orleans
um
all kind of atlanta all kinds of good
days marknomecomedy.com check it out
give it a whirl follow us online check
out our specials we got albums we got
youtube you give it a whirl what do you
got this comes out not this weekend but
the following
so uh yeah you probably just missed me
in indianapolis i'll be in springfield
missouri chicago
denver
phoenix
uh
buffalo
dallas lots of good shape samurai.com
shows yes dr grinstead dr graham and
royal grand rapids
and i'm all over mission the mitten
michigan man
classic yeah um yeah
subscribe to our youtube channel yeah
make sure to uh give us a review on on
the podcast app tell your friends about
us
follow us on social media
and try the patreon i mean check it out
if you get on it send us an email get it
give it a whirl tell a friend
send us a drink a wreck a peeve
patreon.com we might be drunk pod and
email us at we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com the patreon's popping off oh
yeah we're doing all kinds of bonus [ __ ]
you want to be a part of this hell yeah
and check out full capacity on youtube i
think about the 200k on that beauty
maybe i have by now yeah and uh yeah all
the good stuff so
thank you guys thank you queef it up
comedy comedy
[Music]
you